برده نزلت الشغل النهارده
صباح النور سعيده جدا
في التليفون او لما بيشوفوني في اي حته ما
كنتش متوقعه بصراحه كل ده
سعيده جدا فرحانه طبعا جدا ان الناس كلها
حبت ساره وتفاعلت معها وزعلت عليها وفرحت
معها يعني اكيد مبسوطه قوي ما فيش داعي
على فكره انك تخبيها
انا عرفت اللي حصل
استرجب كان بيحكي الاعلامين او سمعت كل
حاجه كنت حابه انها تبقى مختلفه يعني كنت
عايزه الناس تحبها بجد كنت عايزه الناس
تشوفها مختلفه عني انا في الحقيقه شكلها
مختلف
فاشتغلت عليها كثير عشان احاول اعمل ده من
بدايه من الشكل من شكل شعرها من طريقه
الميك اب بتاعها طبعا احنا كنا في حقبه
زمنيه مختلفه فده برده ساعدني كثير انها
ما تطلعش شبهي حبيت احط لها تفاصيل يعني
همم هي حاسه بايه ايه اللي مضيقها همم
تجارب الصعبه اللي عدت بها في حياتها
الحاجات اللي ممكن ما تبقاش مكتوبه بس
ممكن دي تساعدها انها تتاثر بحاجات او
تخليني انا يعني اخليها واحده حقيقيه
عايشه زمان عندها تجارب عندها علاقات
اشتغلت عليها كثير وذاكرتها قوي وحبيت ان
انا اخليها عندها يعني ليهرز
برده مش شرط حتى لو اللي قاعدين فيها
الاوضه اختارتهم مش لازم اول ما يوصل ممكن
يعدي ليله او اثنين لحد ما يحصل حاجه
جدا وفيها كل عوامل النجاح وده كان باين
من الاول بدايه من شركه الانتاج استاذ
ممدوح ثانيا اييه ام بي سي يشاهد طبعا
المخرج الكاست انا بالنسبه لي الكاست كان
مهم جدا لان انا برده لسه في بداياتي
فاكيد لما يبقى معاه ممثلين سؤال زي اللي
موجودين معايا كلهم
اا ده هيفيدني وهيساعدني وهيعلمني اهدا يا
جمال ما تخافش علي انا بقيت كويسه خلاص
شايفه اه اكيد انه الناس حبت ساره قوي
دور ساره سمع مع الناس وحبوه
وانا حبيتها يعني انا حبيتها جدا استمتعت
بكل تفاصيلها اعتقد برده كان نفسي جدا ان
الناس تحبها زي ما انا حبيتها زي ما انا
شفتها زي ما انا حسيت بها يعني انا نفسي
اتاثرت ازاي الناس كلها بالمشهد الاخير
لما شفته بقى لما همم في الحلقه يعني
التاسعه تاثرت جدا
يعني المخرج استاذ محمد بكثير طلعها او
طلع المشهد بالحلاوه دي والله هم بيقولوا
ان في جزء ثاني يعني والاستاذ محمد بكير
يعني بعد الحلقه التاسعه كنا بنتكلم انا
وهو يعني نشوف اجواء الردود الافعال وكده
همم فكان بيقول لي انه ان شاء الله هيبقى
في جزء ثاني ايه اللي هيحصل في الجزء
الثاني بالنسبه لساره ما اعرفش بصراحه بس
هو ان شاء الله هيبقى في الجزء ثاني
بالنسبه لي الاذاعه انا بقالي اكثر من عشر
سنين اكيد ناردين اللي ابتدات في الاذاعه
سنه 2000 او حاجه كده مش هي اللي موجوده
دلوقتي ده اكيد تعلمت حاجات كثير بقيت
مختلفه تماما
الفتره دي تطورت فيها وتعلمت فيها حاجات
كثير خليتني بقيت ناردين المذيعه اللي
بتقف تقدم حاجات مهمه وهمم وتعمل كل
الحاجات خصوصا الحاجات اللي هي بتمثل فيها
بلدي همم كممثله انا بقى لي اربع سنين
فاشتغلت كم عمل ده ممكن يبقى رخامس هل انت
يعني ناردين لسه في حاجات لازم تعمليها
اكيد هل ده مثلا هو سقف ال- ال-
التمثيل او الموهبه بالنسبه لي اكيد لا ف
همم باتعلم حاجات اه طبعا بتعلم حاجات لسه
في حاجات كثير جدا لازم هتعلمها
انا باصور حاليا بين السطور
مع استاذ وائل فرج وصبا مبارك ومحمد علاء
واحمد فهمي وسلمى ابو ضيف وباسر ازارو
وسعيده جدا لكل الخاص
ودور مختلف علي
دراما بقى وفيها مختلف خالص عن الغرفه 207
ف ااا وده اللي انا بصوره حاليا فيعني ان
شاء الله يطلع حلو يعني
[موسيقى]